or cette jeune femme ça fait deux trois
mois qu'il la connaît l'ap à 23 ans
contrairement à ce qu'il a été dit dans
la presse mais 21 ans 21 ans sont en
fait il l'invité chez lui dans son
appartement parisien mais il était déjà
vu déjà déjà eu des relations sexuelles
régulièrement d'accord et puis en fait
don qui lui a demandé de il lui aurait
parce que évidemment il ya la
présomption d'innocence ils se sont
montrés comme ils soumis à la ils se
sont rencontrés lui dans son appart en
l'appartement d'arrêt habitants d'accord
avant sont connus alors à une soirée
avec des amis
comment voilà ils se sont rencontrés à
cette occasion là les ducs ou harry lui
a demandé donc de passer chez lui en
début de soirée samedi et selon les
dires de la victime qui a été entendu
par la police dont il y aurait eu un
rapport sexuel
comment dire non conventionnelles qui
aurait été assez brutales
et pour lequel la victime présumée
aurait dit nyon donc on peut voit la
rentrée dans les faits donc ils sont
sans vie passent la nuit ensemble samedi
soir ce sera alors ça va très vite ils
boivent quelques verres et cetera et
puis très vite harry lui demande
d'alluré demandé d'avoir cette relation
j'avais déjà des relations sont
en fait harry selon selon voilà nos
informations il aurait déjà demandé à
plusieurs reprises d'avoir des rapports
de ce type chose que la victime présumée
aurait toujours refusé
ltd rapport mentionnant demi non
conventionnelles des rapports anaux
voilà donc et est du coup du coup à la
fin arrêt habitants lui aurait donc
demandé d'avoir ce type de rapport elle
aurait refusé et il aurait visiblement
pris
violemment voilà mes étés à monde oblige
à plus trois mois d'accord
reconnaissaient déjà l'état au nom de la
non non ça justifie rien
qu à carreaux il ya qu'est ce qui se
passe exactement parce que voilà donc
c'est si son ensemble donc samedi
c'était en fin de fin de fin de journée
c'est ça débutera demain à priori début
de soirée d'accord donc vous vous avez
vous avez des éléments de 2,7 g pas
d'élément là dessus a tout simplement
déjà c'est une plaignante on n'aime pas
au sein de leurs victimes c'est une
plaignante pour le moment il ya une mise
en examen n'est pas une condamnation il
est présumé innocent maintenant pour
rebondir succès sur ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure si ça n'avait pas été
monsieur ary abittan je ne suis pas
certaine que la main courante qui a
alors expliqué aux téléspectateurs parce
que en fait cette jeune fille a déposé
après donc ça tombe bien car y est allé
une soirée c'est ça c'est ce qui est dit
dans la presse là ils étaient neuf
auraient
alors dans les articles de consommation
dans les articles qu'on a lu qu'ils
avaient pris une douche ensemble au
derrière des ensuite ils ont pas pris de
douche ensemble d'accords que lui dit
après la dictature des eaux oui mais
voilà et derrière ça donc harry est
parti à une soirée c'est ce qu'il lit
dans la presse et la jeune fille elle
est allée au commissariat déposer une
main courante on peut dire ce que c'est
une main courante pour nos
téléspectateurs c'est quoi une main
courante c'est quand vous venez signaler
un fait auprès d'un commissariat mais
accor voulait pas déposé plainte la coff
que ses mains courantes elles sont
transmises pour appréciation au parquet
alors plus ou moins transmises en
fonction de ce qui est dans la main
courante mais là vraisemblablement ils
ont dû juger qu' il fallait la
transmettre immédiatement au procureur
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui est connu
non s'il a été transmis au procureur ça
peu rapide en fait des scores ces colis
s'est passé c'est que elle l'aurait donc
le le samedi soir elle a été
effectivement porté faire une main
courante qu'elle ne voulait pas porter
préjudice
à la carrière selon les selon certains
proches et donc ça a été transmis au
parquet mais elle a donné quand même des
faits matérielles incriminant il y a eu
en fait une perquisition
au domicile
dary habitants ou des
des draps
ensanglanté entre guillemets aurait été
trouvée dans l'appartement est en fait
c'est suite à ces faits matériels que
ary abittan été mis en garde à vue
pendant 48 heures pour dire ses propos
des journalistes y ont été commis ça
parce que voilà c'est la version 6 est
une des versions on est on a peut-être
après utilise le conditionnel c'est sûr
c'est ce que la victime présumée
déclarations ont été faites c'est quoi
c'est dimanche matin la perquisition a
été faite en fin de matinée vers 12h 13h
et donc c'est à la suite de cette
perquisition que ary abittan a été a été
mis en garde à vue elle avait juste posé
nous déposer une main courante la jeune
fille ou en fait c'est le parquet qui
s'est saisi de l affaire parce que c'est
là c'est donc ya pas de naples et pas de
plainte donc si celle ci n'avait pas été
une personne connue est ce que ça aurait
été pareil moi je suis pas certaine du
tout d'accord moi j'ai énormément de
clients qui vont déposé des mains
courantes et ça reste lettre morte est
d'accord ce soit pour des faits de viols
ou de violences conjugales ou autre et
c'est le parquet qui demandait un juge
puisqu'aujourd'hui il a vu un juge
d'accord c'est ça donc il a eu sa mise
en examen il a été il était même ça
c'est obligatoire si je peux me
permettre quand c'est des faits
criminels de la mine elle la saisine du
juge d'instruction elle est obligatoire
voilà mais c'est pour ça qu'il ya quand
même y'a quand même et entre les deux
une confrontation
lundi
évidemment ary abittan a amené les faits
qui lui étaient reprochés
et la jeune femme était était la face à
lui face à lui ce lundi elle était
accompagnée quelqu'un qui veut pas nuire
à sa carrière d'acteur a quand même si
vulgaire énormément d'informations alors
pour un film qui nous a divulgué dans ce
cas là c'est
importe mais voilà c'est l'effet qu'ils
ont été qui ont été communiqués d'accord
oui j'ai la même façon que jeudi à
berlin c'est trop tôt pour en vrai ce
que vous faites là c'est dramatique qui
n'est ni rien parce que ce que vous êtes
vous avez dit maintenant on dirait même
mais juste désolé car maintenant
avec mon savoir-faire pour l'instant
mais
elle est là elle a appris à l'ap a pris
fait et cause il faut
jamais trop d'effets non mérités des
mois benjamin gelé ses prêts sur les i
alors que l appareil et habitant est
coupable je suis pas juge moi je suis en
train de vous dire ce qui a été mis dans
la plainte voilà après tout après moi je
ne suis pas là je ne sais pas si je
n'étais pas là au moment des faits je ne
sais pas ce qui s'est passé est
évidemment que ary abittan et encore est
innocent jusqu'à preuve du 20 juin et à
moins qu'ils aient une condamnation
injuste alors gilles verdez juste m par
rapport à la notoriété vous soulignez
que si ce n'était pas un arrêt habitants
peuvent penser qu' on peut le penser
mais ce qui se passe aussi c'est que
selon mes informations le témoignage
recueilli à était crédible c'est à dire
que c'était une jeune femme qui s'est
présentée qui n'était pas
hystérique étaient très choqués et qui a
donné des éléments matériels il ya eu
des examens et tout de suite et des
égards médico psychologique son
témoignage a été pris au sérieux c'est
pour ça que le parquet a dit on va plus
loin si vous voulez c'est pas forcément
la notoriété c'est aussi la crédibilité
de la plaignante c'est parce que de
toute façon il ya un rapport et il est
pas nier je suis puisque ils disent
qu'il ya eu un rapport consenti au
départ après elle elle dit que le second
rapport est pas consenti lui dit qu'il
est bon
un moment donné c'est la parole de l'un
contre la parole de l'autre on met ça
m'a dit on il juge n'était à l'intérieur
oui mais la mise en examen c'est des
indices graves ou concordants rendant
vraisemblable
vraisemblable ça veut pas dire que c'est
vrai définition donc vraisemblable c'est
vrai que c'est plausible si elle avait
dit j'ai été violée par un mois des jeux
touche environ c'est pas vraisemblable
mais pour prendre un exemple fou voilà
ce que ça veut dire vraisemblablement
fait ça veut tout et rien dire pardon
mais ce que je trouve dramatique c'est
pas ce que vous dites c'est que vous
ayez ce degré d'information et puis ça
qui est pas normal parce qu'après que
vous veniez en parler c'est assez vous
traitiez on vous en fait c'est vrai
brassage et non pas du tout c'est le
procès des gens qui viennent donner
autant d'informations à des gens
n'avaient excusez-moi leur secret
en tradition c'est vraiment pas contre
vous justement je prends votre défense
en disant c'est pas vous qui est
dramatique c'est les gens qui vous
donnent ces informations là voilà c'est
leur degré d'information qui sait les
informations bien sûr elles sont à
prendre avec des pincettes même vous
l'avez dit oui bien sûr c'est bien sûr
la version de la jeune fille voilà là on
donne la vère femme moi je donne la
version des relations de barry pour
l'instant lui nie les faits dit que les
rapports étaient consentis lui dit même
qu'ils se connaissaient pas depuis
longtemps voilà donc donc voilà ils ont
des versions qui sont pas du tout
compatible